I don't mean to brag,
but there are lots of things
that I'm pretty average at.
From playing table tennis,
cooking risotto,
finding countries on a map,
just to name a few.
Now, in our everyday lives,
we're not typically assessed
on our skills and abilities,
so we're forced to rely
on our own judgments.
I may think I'm pretty decent
with Italian cuisine,
but how accurate is my assessment?
Now, what we’re talking
about here is metacognition:
our insight into our own
thought processes.
If I have good metacognitive insight,
then how good I think I am
at a particular task
should line up pretty well
with how good I actually am.
Of course, in the real world
this is often not the case.
And indeed, we probably all know someone
who thinks they're great
at navigating maps,
when in fact the reality
is often the opposite.
Not to name any names,
of course, but still.
Perhaps you think this applies
to other people
and that you, yourself, wouldn't make
this sort of mistake.
So let's try a quick experiment.
I want you to think about how
you would rate yourself
in terms of your driving ability.
Would you rate yourself
as below average, average
or perhaps even above average?
So most people rate themselves
as above average,
which, of course,
is mathematically impossible,
and something that we call
the "better than average" effect.
This is just one of a number
of cognitive biases that we see
when people judge their own abilities.
Today, I'm going
to focus on a related bias,
the Dunning-Kruger effect.
So back in 1999,
two psychologists at Cornell University,
Dunning and Kruger,
described the mistakes people make
when estimating their own abilities.
So if we take a sample of people
and we divide them into four groups
based on their scores on a test,
and order those groups
from lowest to highest.
If we plot those scores on a graph
along with their self-estimates,
so how well they thought
they did on the test,
this is the pattern that we see.
So the red line is a steep slope
representing their actual scores.
As it must be, since we ordered the groups
based on their scores in the first place.
Now what's interesting
is the blue shallower line.
This represents their self-estimates.
So, how good they thought
they did on the test.
Now the Dunning-Kruger effect
describes how the weakest performers
significantly overestimate
their performance,
shown here in the green oval.
The explanation for this,
according to Dunning and Kruger,
is that insight and ability
rely on the same thing.
So if I'm poor at a task,
I also lack the metacognitive insight
to accurately assess my ability.
Now this pattern has been seen
again and again
across a number of domains,
from driving skill to exam-taking,
even chess-playing.
However, in recent years,
a number of criticisms
have been leveled at this approach,
and we now have reason to believe
that this pattern results
is virtually unavoidable.
One reason for this
is the statistical effect,
regression to the mean.
Now this is something that comes about
when we have two measures
that are related but not perfectly so.
So imagine we have a sample of people
and we measure their heights
and their weights.
Now height and weight are related,
tall people are typically heavier,
but the relationship is far from perfect.
So unlike in the figure at the top here,
the shortest people in red
won't all be the lightest people.
Some of them will be overweight
or particularly muscular, for example.
Similarly at the top end,
the tallest people in blue
won't all be the heaviest people.
Some of them will be
underweight, and so on.
Now as a result, on average,
the shortest people will rank higher
for weight than they do for height,
and the tallest people will rank lower
for weight than they do for height
producing this blue line here
and the crossover pattern
you're now becoming familiar with.
Now, some people might put forward
a spurious explanation
for why short people
are relatively overweight
or tall people relatively underweight,
when in fact no explanation is needed.
Perhaps more compelling a reason
to doubt the Dunning-Kruger effect
is that we can produce
the same pattern in our data
when our data is entirely meaningless.
So if we collect people's test scores
along with their self-estimates
of those scores,
but then we shuffle those self-estimates
and then analyze as before,
then we still find that same
pattern in the data.
Of course, any effect that we can find
with shuffled or randomized data
is one that we should surely
be suspicious of.
So, given these and other issues
with the Dunning-Kruger approach,
I was saddened and disappointed
and, frankly, a little annoyed to discover
that the same approach
was now being applied
in my field of expertise,
which is face-matching.
Now, this is a task where
we're showing two images of faces
or an image and a live person,
and we're asked to decide
whether they show the same person
or two different people.
Now, we've all stood in line
at passport control,
anxiously awaiting the passport
officer's decision
as to whether our ID photos
look sufficiently like us or not.
Indeed, I've included at the top here
some examples of ID images
from my own life,
just to illustrate some variability.
Some proud moments
in photographic history,
I'm sure you'll agree.
And so what I'd like to do now
is first see how well you might perform
as passport officers.
So here are four pairs of images,
some students’ ID images
and some student photos.
For each pair, I'd like you
to decide whether it's a match,
so two images of the same person,
or a mismatch,
two images of different people.
Some of you might be surprised to hear
that the top two pairs are matches,
so images of the same people,
and the bottom two pairs show mismatches,
so two different people.
Now we know this task
is particularly difficult
when the images show identities
that we're unfamiliar with.
This is because it's hard
to take into account the changes
that can happen to the face across time,
as well as over different situations,
so changes in facial expression
or lighting, for instance.
We know this task is difficult
for passport officers as well,
and they also make mistakes.
So this is why I thought
it would be particularly interesting
to look at the relationship
between insight and ability
in this important security context.
So given the issues
we’ve described already
with looking at overall scores
and people’s self-estimates,
I instead decided to focus
on individual decision making.
So over a series of experiments,
I asked people to look at pairs of images
and decide whether they were
a match or a mismatch.
But I also asked people to provide
a rating of confidence in each decision.
Now a good metacognitive insight
would be reflected in people
being much more confident
in decisions that turned out
to be correct
and much less confident in decisions
that turned out to be incorrect.
So let's have a look at how people did.
Now I think this pattern
is particularly fascinating,
but also fairly intuitive.
Let's start with the red line,
which represents people's confidence
in their incorrect responses.
So as you can see,
it doesn't matter how good
people were at the test overall,
represented by the score
on the X-axis at the bottom there;
people were approximately the same
in terms of their confidence
when they were incorrect.
Now what's interesting is the blue line,
which represents confidence when people
were correct in their decisions.
As you can see, the best
performers on the test
were much more confident
in their correct responses
in comparison with their incorrect ones.
So shows good metacognitive insight.
The weakest performers, on the other hand,
were no different in their confidence
for their correct and incorrect responses,
shown here in the green circle.
And so they show poor
metacognitive insight.
So what might be going on
with these weak performers?
Now it could be the case
that they have some sense
they tend to perform poorly
on tests in general,
and so they're just less confident
overall in their responses.
However, I didn't find that pattern
of lower confidence in my data,
at least with individual decision-making.
Instead, it's more likely that they were
more confident in their correct responses
in comparison with their incorrect ones.
But this was simply unrelated
to their accuracy on each trial
because they had poor insight.
So how does this all fit in
with the Dunning-Kruger effect?
So Dunning and Kruger argued
that the weakest performers
show the least amount of insight
and they overestimated their performance.
And that's implied that they
had greater confidence.
Now, we didn't see that here in our data.
The weakest performers
didn't seem to be overly confident.
However, the Dunning-Kruger effect
also describes how insight
depends on ability.
And so the weakest performers
showed the least amount of insight,
overestimating their
performance in their case.
As we've just seen,
the weakest performers do seem to show
the least amount of insight.
Here, they couldn't differentiate between
their correct and incorrect responses.
So insight does appear
to depend on ability,
but not in the way that Dunning
and Kruger originally thought.
So if there are two things I'd like you
to remember from this talk
and take home, think about afterwards,
they are: first, more broadly,
science is always updating.
Research comes along,
new evidence that may contradict
or even disprove previous work.
In this case, the Dunning-Kruger
effect may well not be a thing,
despite the fact that it's
so prevalent in popular culture.
Second, insight depends on ability.
For the weakest performers,
there's no difference
between their confidence
for correct and incorrect responses.
They have poor insight,
they can't tell the difference.
For strong performers,
when they're giving a correct answer,
they're much more confident.
Of course, the inverse isn't always true.
Being more confident
doesn't mean that you're right.
You might be wrong
and simply have poor insight.
So in our everyday lives,
you should think about who it is
that you ask the opinions of.
If someone is an expert in their field,
then if they're more confident,
they're probably right,
but if they're unsure,
this is also informative
and tells us something useful.
It's much more sensible to find someone
that we know is knowledgeable in an area,
rather than someone who is simply
confident in their opinion,
because confidence is easily misplaced.
And finally,
for those of you who are still wondering
how good my risotto actually is,
that may have to wait for a future talk.
Thank you.
(Applause)